bonjour à tous même si on s'y connait
mieux sur les collectivités
territoriales
grâce à la vidéo qui les a définis une
grande question reste en suspens qui
s'occupe de quoi qui est en charge de
quoi entre les régions les départements
et les communes
on va pas se mentir c'est plutôt
complexe de s'y retrouver
alors retrousse les manches et on y va
donc oui l'organisation territoriale
française est un peu complexe
c'est dû à notre histoire qui nous a
laissé énormément de communes et de
département mais c'est aussi dû à la
complexité de la réalité du terrain
du coup pour clarifier les choses l'état
a mis en place un principe de transfert
de compétences par bloc
cela permet à chaque échelon des
collectivités territoriales de posséder
des compétences propres est clairement
défini par la loi et même si ce principe
de transfert de compétence n'est pas
toujours complètement respecté il donne
tout de même aux collectivités
territoriales des rôles de chef de file
pour certains grands domaines c'est
comme ça que la région se retrouve être
le chef de file en matière d'aménagement
et de développement durable du
territoire de protection de la
biodiversité du climat de la qualité de
l'air et de l'énergie
elle se trouve aussi être chef de file
en matière de développement économique
de soutien de l'innovation et de
l'internationalisation des entreprises
c'est aussi la région qui est en charge
de l'organisation de la liaison et de la
complémentarité des modes de transport
enfin elle est aussi en charge de la
gestion des lycées concernant le
département il devient chef de file en
matière d'action et de développement
social pour l'autonomie des personnes et
contre la précarité énergétique par
exemple
et le département cd collège d'antibes
s'occupe quant au secteur communal
l'accent est mis sur l'organisation des
services publics de proximité comme la
police municipale par exemple c'est
aussi le secteur communal qui a pour
mission la mise en place de moyens de
déplacement moins nuisible pour
l'environnement c'est aussi lui qui
s'occupe de l'aménagement de l'espace et
du développement local
enfin concernant l'enseignement le
secteur communal s'occupe de l'école
primaire
bien sûr cette liste n'est pas complète
ce n'est qu'un résumé je vous invite à
aller voir sur le site vie publique.fr
pour voir le partage des compétences
dans le détail certaines compétences
néanmoins reste partagée par la région
le département et la commune dans
certains domaines communs aux trois
échelons c'est pour ça que les
compétences en matière de culture de
sport le tourisme par exemple sont
partagés sur les trois niveaux
aussi il ne faut pas non plus oublier
que sur le terrain le dialogue entre les
différentes collectivités est une
évidence par exemple pour implanter un
collège ou un lycée dans une ville le
département ou la région se mettront
d'accord avec la commune pour aménager
les zones résidentielles autour des
bâtiments
mais ce qu'il faut en retenir c'est que
cette nouvelle définition des
compétences donne un plus grand rôle aux
régions qu'elles diminuent le rôle des
départements et qu'elle renforce
l'intercommunalité
d'ailleurs si dans cette vidéo je parle
parfois de secteur communal plutôt que
de communes ou d'intercommunalité
c'est parce qu'on fera une petite vidéo
dessus dans le futur pour préciser les
différences mais si on veut faire bref
on peut dire que le plus souvent les
intercommunalités s'occupe des domaines
communs à plusieurs communes comme le
traitement des eaux de tourisme ou le
développement économique
voilà c'est fini merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo jusqu'au bout j'espère
qu'elle vous aidera à y voir un peu plus
clair concernant les compétences des
collectivités territoriales si vous
voulez approfondir le sujet allez faire
un tour sur le site de vie publique tout
il sera expliqué à bientôt